We've just made an interactive
InVision prototype.
Well done.
>> Remember though, the vital part
of prototyping is iteration and
constant improvement.
We got some feedback at the end
of the last lesson, and
we decided on a few potential changes.
>> It's now time to implement those
changes in our interactive prototype.
Jay Can you remind me
what those changes were?
>> Yeah.
The main feedback we received revolved
around the task functionality
not being clear.
Carl suggested making the main screen be
our day screen which had the checkboxes.
We also decided that it would be best to
have those checkboxes have some higher
visibility and visual weight.
Finally, we decided that our wording
around task and events was unclear.
Remember, we had intended for
them to be the same object, but
we've used two different words for them.